alors comment ça fonctionne donc il ya
une radiocommande en fait qui permet
d'aller à droite ou à gauche
et puis une gâchette qui permet d'aller
en avant et en arrière donc il ya un
deuxième opérateur qui s'occupe de faire
tourner la caméra à 360 degrés dans les
trois axes de l'espace pour cadrer le
sujet battu raymond ne travaille pas sur
un projet top secret de la nasa mais
chez acs france le spécialiste français
de la prise de vue aérienne est en
mouvement
aujourd'hui ce pilote de drones présente
au public le dernier né de l'entreprise
un buggy avec un système de caméra trois
axes qui peut aller jusqu'à 120 km heure
c'est utilisé pour tout ce qui est filmé
de course à pied ou de voitures ou des
plans assez dynamique et c'est aussi
utilisé dans le sport pour l'aider suivi
de des suivis de d'athlètes dans
l'effort ou ce genre de mouvement
toujours des mouvements en action assez
rapide
cette innovation rejoint la caverne
d'ali baba technologiques de
l'entreprise le siège est implanté à
bucca en stock des dizaines de drones
des voitures équipées de caméras et des
grues le public présent ce jeudi 6 avril
pendant ces journées portes ouvertes a
été plongé dans un film de science
fiction
il ya vraiment
que du matériel un peu spécifique et
tout ne s'est pas
du matériel qu'on a l'habitude de voir
tous les jours
un côté avant gardiste qui plaît au
monde audiovisuel français et
international l'entreprise enregistré
l'année dernière un chiffre d'affaires
compris entre 2,5 et 3 millions d'euros
et vient de collaborer avec des grosses
productions hollywoodiennes comme
transformers 5 qui sortira en juin
prochain
on a un savoir-faire de 20 ans une
technologie qui est technologie de
pointe on essaye aujourd'hui d'investir
dans du matériel qui fonctionne on peut
comparer à la bentley rolls royce
mercedes avec quelque chose qui est
vraiment bien la boutique pour observer
en direct ce matériel dernier cri il
faudra patienter jusqu'à former la
quinzaine du tournoi de tennis roland
garros
l'un des plus anciens partenaires de la
structure cette histoire dure depuis